[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y lima y continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
en Colombia seis soldados perdieron la
vida y otros siete resultaron heridos en
el sur occidente del país tras un ataque
de las disidencias de la antigua
guerrilla de las FARC los hechos se
presentan pese a la política de paz
total del presidente Gustavo Petro
tenemos análisis
a poco del inicio de la cop 15 la
conferencia de Naciones Unidas sobre
biodiversidad la Unión Europea logró un
acuerdo pionero que prohíbe importar
productos que hayan contribuido de
alguna forma a la deforestación como el
cacao la carne o el café en ciertas
regiones
la cadena de noticias cataría yacira
presentó ante la Corte Penal
Internacional del caso de asesinato de
la periodista palestino estadounidense
Quien murió en medio del fuego cruzado
durante una redada israelí en
cisjordania en mayo pasado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en Argentina porque un
tribunal de ese país condenó a la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández a seis
años de prisión e inhabilitación para
ejercer cargos públicos en un caso
conocido a nivel mediático como vialidad
la dos veces presidenta fue sentenciada
por dirigir una organización delictiva
para otorgar contratos de Obras Públicas
que le costaron millones de dólares a la
nación y que no fueron terminadas pese a
la decisión judicial este caso podría
tardar en resolverse
la justicia Argentina emitió sentencia
para uno de los casos más polémicos en
toda su historia Cristina Fernández de
kirchner vicepresidenta y ex mandataria
de la nación fue condenada por un caso
de corrupción el cual habría tenido
lugar entre 2003 y 2015 condenar a
Cristina Elizabeth Fernández de kirchner
a la pena de seis años de prisión
inhabilitación especial perpetua para
ejercer cargos públicos accesorias
legales y las costas del proceso por
considerar la autora penalmente
responsable del delito de administración
fraudulenta en perjuicio de la
Administración pública el juicio inició
en mayo de 2019 y es conocido como caso
vialidad la fiscalía pedía 12 años de
prisión para la líder política luego de
acusar la de liderar una asociación
ilícita que gestionó el otorgamiento de
51 Obras Públicas al empresario Lázaro
báez cercano al matrimonio kirchner
sin embargo no se trata de una condena
firme dado que quien fuera dos veces
presidenta del país deberá esperar a que
se den a conocer los fundamentos de la
condena previstos para 2023
Residen a partir de ese momento podrá
apelar
la política de 69 años cuenta con fueros
que la blindan de una eventual detención
hasta diciembre de 2023 cuando termine
su mandato como vicepresidenta la
política quien ha negado desde el primer
día las acusaciones y asegura ser
víctima de una persecución política
escuchó su sentencia de manera virtual
esta condena con Patriotas no es una
condena por las leyes de la Constitución
o por las leyes administrativas o por el
código penal esto es un estado paralelo
y mafia mafia judicial entre tanto miles
de argentinos salieron a las calles a
reaccionar frente a este caso que divide
aún más a una sociedad ya polarizada y
parece estar lejos de llegar a su fin
vamos ahora a Colombia porque seis
soldados murieron en medio de un
enfrentamiento con disidencias de la
extinta guerrilla de las FARC los hechos
ocurrieron en el departamento del cauca
en el sur occidente del país el
presidente Gustavo Petro aseguró que el
ataque tiene que con rutas del
narcotráfico para analizar la situación
de seguridad en regiones de Colombia
conectamos con Andrés Macías él es
docente investigador de la Universidad
externado de Colombia y experto en temas
de paz y conflicto Bienvenido a France
24 Cómo se pueden analizar estos hechos
en medio de la estrategia de paz total
de Petro esto al tiempo que la fundación
ideas para la paz destacó que los
homicidios son descendido un 8% desde
que el mandatario asumió el cargo y que
es una cifra que pues no es suficiente
Valentina buenas noches para ti y para
todos los que nos escuchan el día de hoy
Bueno frente lo que mencionas
la iniciativa del presidente Petro de la
paz total y el acercamiento con
diferentes grupos fue muy positivo y
abre un espectro de Esperanza importante
para tratar de reducir los niveles de
violencia en el país pero no podemos
esperar que se reduzcan los homicidios
de manera inmediata los grupos con los
que se ha empezado a entablar algún tipo
de conversación real es el eln y según
informó el presidente en el día de hoy
vaya si no estoy mal es que se están
adelantando también con un grupo de
jóvenes de una organización
delincuencial en Buenaventura pero más
allá de eso no hay acercamientos
concretos por lo tanto el contexto de
violencia sigue algunos grupos como el
frente Jaime Martínez del Comando
coordinador de occidente ha expresado su
voluntad de negociar o de acogerse a esa
Paz total pero no hay nada concreto y
mientras no haya nada concreto no
podemos esperar una reducción de
violencia por parte de esos grupos
bueno justamente usted lo estaba
mencionando esta disminución de
homicidios es una prioridad para el
mandatario por ejemplo en la ciudad de
Buenaventura en el Pacífico colombiano
una de las más golpeadas por la
violencia en el país pues lleva 80 días
sin registrar homicidios pero en
ciudades del Caribe han subido en un 23%
que se puede analizar de esta
desigualdad
Pues que los homicidios no responden
únicamente al contexto de violencia
asociado al conflicto armado o a la
violencia y a los a las afectaciones al
orden público ocasionado por estos
grupos delincuenciales los homicidios
tienen una
motivación una causa que va más allá de
la existencia de estos grupos por lo
tanto no podemos asociar las iniciativas
de paz total con reducción inmediata a
domicilios y en diferentes regiones hay
diferentes actores con diferentes
dinámicas y por eso en el Caribe la
dinámica es diferente a lo que sucede en
Buenaventura o lo que sucede en Cali o
lo que sucede en Bogotá o en el sur del
país y más aún cuando hay muchos grupos
que operan en diferentes partes y hay
una disputa territorial entre cada uno
de ellos bueno otro tema que llama la
atención es el aumento de asesinatos de
líderes ambientales ellos que defienden
la tierra que suele estar en la mira de
los actores ilícitos que nos dice esta
cifra
pues es que es un reto enorme para el
gobierno del presidente Petro lograr
reducir la violencia contra todo tipo de
líderes y más aún con líderes
ambientales que ha sido una de las
banderas de su campaña de su gobierno y
es un reto que el presidente ha tratado
de empezar a a lidiar pero que todavía
le hace falta mucho poder
operacionalizar la protección de cada
uno de estos líderes en diferentes
partes del país porque nuevamente las
afectaciones a cada uno de los líderes
en cada una de las regiones varía y la
seguridad de ellos es una prioridad
frente a lo cual diferentes gobiernos no
solamente el actual sino diferentes
gobiernos han tratado de incidir y
desafortunadamente no lo han logrado
hacer de manera satisfactoria pues señor
Macías a usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en France 24
Muchas gracias gracias Valentina y un
saludo para toda tu audiencia gracias
continuamos con otros temas porque la
conferencia sobre biodiversidad
cop25 empieza en pocos minutos en pocas
en pocas horas y la Unión Europea selló
un acuerdo sin precedentes para prohibir
la importación de productos si
contribuyen a la deforestación la
conferencia buscará lograr un acuerdo
post 2020 ambicioso y efectivo luego de
que Naciones Unidas destacará que la
humanidad ha afectado al menos el 75% de
la masa terrestre y el 66% de los
océanos de los océanos veamos los
detalles en el siguiente informe
los bosques asiáticos diezmados
sustituidos por palmeras de aceite o
hebeas miles de hectáreas de Selva
brasileña quemadas a causa del cultivo
de soya es para luchar contra estos
fenómenos devastadores que el parlamento
europeo y los Estados miembros de la
Unión Europea han firmado un acuerdo
histórico
cacao cafés soya pero también aceite de
Palma madera carne de vacuno y caucho a
partir de ahora se prohibirá la
importación de estos productos si
proceden de tierras deforestadas después
de diciembre de 2020 un gran paso
adelante bien recibido por los
ecologistas es la primera vez en el
mundo es el café que desayunamos el
chocolate que comemos el carbón de
nuestras barbacoas el papel de nuestros
libros es radical la decisión de la
Unión Europea no solo cambia las reglas
del juego para el consumo europeo sino
que crea un enorme incentivo para que
otros países cambien sus prácticas
varios materiales asociados como el
cuero papel impreso o carboncillo
también se ven afectados las empresas
importa tendrán que demostrar la
trazabilidad de estos productos una
decisión sin precedentes mientras que la
Unión Europea es responsable del 16% de
la deforestación mundial lo que le
convierte en el segundo mayor destructor
de bosques tropicales por detrás de
China la ong wwwf lamenta sin embargo un
acuerdo imperfecto sobre todo porque aún
no se refiere a otros ecosistemas
forestales amenazados como la sabana del
cerrado en Brasil la ongs lamenta que la
protección sea demasiado precaria para
los pueblos indígenas porque se basa en
la legislación local que es desigual de
un país a otro
en otras noticias el presidente de
Ucrania abuelo de mirza lensky visitó a
las tropas que están en el frente de
batalla en la región del Don Baz
Asimismo a soldados heridos en combate
quienes agradecieron la presencia del
mandatario y reiteraron su compromiso
con su nación Catalina Gómez Ángel
enviada especial de France 24 nos amplió
los detalles
estas calles oscuras no son
características solo de la ciudad de
slobians donde los encontramos sino de
las mayoría de las ciudades en el don
Baz donde si bien la Luz va y viene
durante las horas de la noche las calles
permanecen oscuras y aquí en slobians
donde nos encontramos hubo el gran acto
de las fuerzas militares que celebran su
día hoy en Ucrania aquí estuvo el
presidente bolodomirse y Aunque
realmente no se le vio en las calles el
público luego un video en el que se leía
que estaba la entrada de dislomian si se
reunió con un gran número de militares a
quienes rindió honores por la labor que
en esta zona de Ucrania donde él bien lo
dijo celebran las principales batallas
actualmente y esto es especialmente
evidente en la población de bacmut en la
provincia de donesc que si bien los
rusos las fuerzas rusas están tratando
de tomar desde meses de junio y de Julio
han reforzado esa batalla en los últimos
días los soldados y la poca población
que queda ahí están en sótanos son
atacados permanentemente y también por
un gran número de refuerzos de las
tropas rusas que son en mayor número
después de ese reclutamiento masivo de
los últimos meses aún así los ucranianos
siguen teniendo el control de esta
población y de muchas otras de esta
región del presidente le recordó hoy que
espera que el año entrante esta
provincia esté totalmente en control de
Ucrania y es que recordemos que la lucha
aquí se Libra desde el 2014 contra los
separatistas de estas provincias de que
ya tenían en su poder bastante
territorio y que se ha ido aumentando
desde que comenzó la guerra el 24 de
febrero esto también es llega y este
visita de Selena es que llegan un
momento en que las situaciones bastante
dura porque han bajado las temperaturas
estamos a menos 10 grados centígrados y
esto es bastante difícil especialmente
para los soldados que están en el frente
la noticia la cadena de noticias cataría
el jazzira presentó ante la Corte Penal
Internacional el caso de la asesinato de
la periodista palestino estadounidense
que murió durante una redada israelí en
sisjordania en mayo pasado las cpi debe
identificar a las personas que
estuvieron directamente implicadas en el
asesinato pese a las controvertidas
circunstancias que envolvieron el hecho
sin ningún responsable por su muerte la
familia de sharin abue y la cadena para
la que trabajaba la periodista han
decidido dar un paso adelante llevar su
caso ante la Corte Penal Internacional
para sostener su tesis que sharin fue
asesinada por las fuerzas israelíes
mi familia sigue sin saber quién disparó
esa bala mortal Y quién participó en la
cadena de Mando que permitió que mataran
a mi tía
fue asesinada a disparos mientras cubría
una redada del ejército israelí en
jenning en la cisjordania ocupada el 11
de mayo en septiembre Israel reconoció
que probablemente fue un error de alguno
de sus soldados pero se negó a perseguir
al culpable ahora los abogados del
yasira aseguran tener nuevas pruebas de
la autoría y del carácter intencional
del crimen las imágenes de video
demuestran claramente que las fuerzas de
defensas israelí dispararon directamente
contra sharin y sus compañeros
todo el mundo puede presentar casos ante
la cpi y es el tribunal quien decide si
tomarlos o no una investigación a la que
Estados Unidos socio histórico de Israel
se ha opuesto
en 2021 la cpi Ya abrió un caso por
crímenes de guerra en el conflicto
palestino israelí algo que da Esperanza
a los familiares para que el caso siga y
se consiga justicia para
n cerramos esta informativo con noticias
del mundial de fútbol de Qatar y la
sorpresiva victoria de Marruecos frente
a España en octavos de final esto les
permite clasificar por primera vez a la
ronda de cuartos Y ser el único equipo
africano que sigue en el Torneo las
calles del país se convirtieron en una
auténtica fiesta como podemos ver en
estas imágenes de Sofía catalá
corresponsal de France 24
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a que continúen con nosotros
que ya llega a la pantalla nuestro
programa corresponsales feliz noche para
todos
[Música]